I can't believe this is my first time
having them
if you eat them with a fork and a knife
like we'll be like oh
like they're they're stuck up they're
bougie
she was like I am blue
in that cave
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Curly and
today I've invited some of my friends to
come over and binge watch some of our
favorite Prime video shows together from
the boys to Lucy and Desi Prime Video
has an amazing collection that you can
watch from your favorite movies to your
favorite shows that you can watch with
friends your family or even by yourself
and since we all love exploring new
foods we thought let's have a potluck so
we all prepare dishes from our own
cultures for each of us to try I brought
papoosas and they don't know this but I
actually didn't cook my own dish
oh I have to go oh my God guys thank you
so much for coming oh boys I'm so
excited to see your home it looks so
beautiful all your delicious dishes
thank you for inviting me oh my god of
course should we make ourselves plates
and yes let's dig in do it
we're gonna start here I made these you
better eat all of them
everybody watch raisins everything in it
oh you're so sweet baby oh she's so
sweet
so we eat them in Puerto Rico all the
time I grew up eating them getting them
at the Puerto Rican restaurant by my
house they are delicious you can have
them as a side or I just eat them by
myself they're so good what role would
food play in the documentary of your
life it's my passion it's what filled my
fire it's what makes me money
it'll be really important what about you
my grandma's dementia now but when I was
younger one of the things that we used
to do is we would make pupusas together
and so she would teach me like the
rhythm of doing it with the hands if you
mess up you put a little bit more masa
in there it's something that gets passed
down and now I do it with my mom too
like we just do it in the house it's
something that we can kind of bond over
mine always come out really ugly but
they taste good you gotta taste good
that's what I mean
thank you so much that zucchini is
seasoned
I think like growing up like my mom and
I kind of had like a little bit of a
tumultuous relationship so now we Bond
over like cooking and doing things and
then we'll like sit down and watch a
show that we like so right now we're
actually watching A League of Their Own
which I super love
um how is that it's really good I mean
if you like baseball you'll like it I
love you like like your time girl stuff
damn stuff there's a little bit of like
a queer vibe that everything I love that
I feel like we're like Diego Luna's new
show it's pretty good it's actually
really good four people they're sitting
around eating and chatting about really
cool ideas I'm just really cute to look
at yeah that part it's been a while
Tony have you seen that Jay Baldwin
documentary that just came out I love
the boy from Medellin no actually I saw
the trailer it looks so good it does
look and I love him I love his music he
kind of is like trying to figure out if
he should speak up politically or not
and I'm like it's true like do artists
do that should they not like what is the
right thing to do it brings like a tough
subject yeah
foreign
I feel like when I'm hanging out with my
friends I want something that's exciting
that's eye-catching that's going to keep
you at the edge of your seats just like
the boys I feel like with that show I'm
constantly like what is going on how bad
can homelander get and what is going on
with the sea guy I don't know everything
about that show keeps me have you guys
seen that news documentary by the way
about Lucy and Desi
I'm obsessed I grew up watching them
like I would watch um I Love Lucy every
day with my booty in the morning and my
grandma didn't really speak a lot of
English and there's a lot of Spanish in
the show too growing up you know I was
one of 12 grandkids and one of the
favorite things my grandma Solange used
to make was her sweet potato pudding and
she was a caterer so she was so good at
cooking so good this is amazing I love
it I brought my grandma's pudding
because I wanted some comfort food in
case you guys wanted to watch a war I
love horror horror I like Thrillers not
[ __ ] I love
have you guys seen Bingo how I saw the
trailer it's about like these abuelas
who are like in a Bengal Hall and
they're like going nuts did it look
scary I mean
I mean so what can I I'm sorry
I'm so down things get a little
bit really scared but let's do it I got
my my pudding I can do it all right
y'all make sure you make yourself a good
plate with some good people and watch
Prime videos Hispanic Heritage Month
collection where you can watch great
movies and great shows of great people
he loves us I do uh I like your food a
little bit more though
questions